за 11 лютого до України не змогло в них
цієї близько 200 російських four на
кордоні з Білорусі вже те морські
області активістами самооборони натовп
майдану блоку вали головний автомобільний
транзитний коридор з Росії саме в
воді та шниви не так ми до вас хлопці
претензії на моєму у ряди так роблять
робить ну ось все з усієї шишки на на
випадок ми воюємо він з Росії а в кремлі
їм граматики та активісти вимагають
повністю за брун це російський монтаж
не прив'язаним до гінер
поважається адекватна відповідь і на
російське ембарго на українську їжу
та на за оборону транзит українців
фантазію і головна атака і в криму то
на донбасі біду ряду потрібно буде
вирішу чим а не прошивати і вашими нашими
ми наш ряд і наша влада wanna за
спиздити і
враховує на акції протесту кабіну хвали
у рішенні проти годинника запинку
російського транзиту так і стан роти
протестували кента шкіряна за задоволена
брати зрозуміти свою акцію протесту та
відчуває тут сила дубова
виїзду російських four прани вони на тему
про кордону у пам'ятайте перепустки активісти
на та стрибку джайю то грошей українська
фурам за рішення Москви s2 на титова
лютого в залі паркан похмурої простоватість
території федерації там зуби на на
на 300 українських фантазі вак то росія
прийняла русів жила абсолютно
неадекватні заходи загнала машини до
українською машину та поїхав і території
росії за зали nike штраф майданчики як
за ручних і не знаю як заручник на
адже не знаю як назвати цьому ми
думали про declined дзеркальний заходу та
нам прийняти якісь гарбуз лапок і
ранку мій масі вид підземних методів
поки утримуємось від подібних методів
на розвід блокади вийшло також 11
областей України